well as we mentioned the president is
getting ready to sign a new trade
agreement with Canada and Mexico he is
of course at the g20 summit in Buenos
Aires it is one of several critical
meetings on his agenda but his decision
to cancel talks with Russian President
Vladimir Putin is making headlines major
Garrett is at the summit in Buenos Aires
major good morning good morning
president Trump abruptly canceled two
meetings scheduled here with Vladimir
Putin doing so via Twitter aboard Air
Force One on his way here and just
moments after telling reporters on the
South Lawn the White House those Putin
meetings were still on the stated reason
for this jarring reversal us displeasure
over Russia's seizing last weekend of
Ukrainian Navy vessels and sailors the
most brazen act of aggression by Russia
against Ukraine on president Trump's
watch Putin for his part just arrived
here and Moscow said this morning it
believes these meetings were canceled
for quote domestic reasons unquote in
the United States back on Ukraine German
Chancellor Angela Merkel vows to
confront Putin while here at the g20
over this act of aggression meanwhile
president Trump's schedule remains
scattered formal talks with leaders of
Turkey and South Korea have been
downgraded and whether or not the
president interacts at all with Saudi
Crown Prince Mohammed bin Salman remains
an open question the crown prince here
at the g20 likely to receive a very
frosty reception in the aftermath of the
kingdom admitting it killed journalist
Jamal khashoggi inside the Saudi
consulate in Turkey in early October
lastly today is a holiday here in Buenos
Aires large-scale protests against the
g20 and globalization are expected in
the streets security is very tight and
the summit site is barricaded and blocks
away from the designated protest zone
guys it's fair to say this is not your
typical g20 summit a lot to pay
attention to major Garrett thank you